we were expecting um the jury
to deliver its conclusions on the
fishmongers
hall terror attack in which jack merritt
25 and saskia jones 23
were fatally stabbed um and we are
hearing
now let me get that out for you that um
the jury has concluded that saskia jones
who was 23
and jack merritt who was 25
were unlawfully killed so um that
is the inquest jury into their deaths
in the fishmonger's hall terror attack
it has concluded that
saskia jones and jack merritt were
unlawfully qui
um unlawfully killed excuse me um
there you have saskia jones she was 23
when she was killed
jack marriott he was 25 there he is and
they were fatally stabbed by
usman khan it was an alumni event for
cambridge universities
learning together there is uh learning
together offender educational
organization
it was in london you may remember it
november the 29th
of 2019. now it's taken
six weeks for a jury at the guildhall in
london
it's had first-hand accounts of the
attack and
witnesses outlining authorities dealings
with osman khan before
beforehand
he launches attack as i said on the 29th
of um november of 29
2019 inside the
learning together event which is in the
fishmongers hall on the north side of
london
bridge um miss jones
saskia jones she was a volunteer at the
event and she died from a stab wound to
her neck
um jack merritt he was one of the
organizers of that event
he was stabbed 12 times including a
fatal wound
to the test to his chest as i said it
was almost two months of evidence at the
guild hall
in the city of london and the jury was
told that usman
khan had planned and carried out this
attack
11 months after he was released from
prison he was jailed
in 2012 for his part in what was a
foiled terrorist
plot to blow up the london stock
exchange
and so 2012 usman khan was jailed for
his part in
what was a failed terrorist plot as well
as plans to set up a terrorist
training camp um now in those six weeks
of testimony the
inquest has heard that on a number of
occasions
intelligence on usman khan was not
properly shared
between all interested parties um
there were two days of closing remarks
and the coroner mark lurecroft told the
jury they'd have to address
three main issues one was how
a former terrorist prisoner had was
managed
on his release from prison i'm going to
leave it there and we're going to bring
in our home affairs correspondent
mark white what's the latest mark
well clearly significant criticism in
the verdicts that have been delivered by
the jury here in the inquest into the
deaths of saskia jones and
jack merritt back in november of 2019
with
particular criticism about the way in
which huzman khan
was managed in the community he had been
released from prison
some 11 months before he carried out
this terrorist attack he had been jailed
of course
in 2012 for his part in a plot to
detonate a bomb at the london stock
exchange
and to set up a terrorist training camp
when he was
let out the security services and the
police did believe that
he was still an individual who posed a
significant risk
but intelligence on that key
intelligence
was never properly shared between
different agencies and
those agencies were talking about the
police with the prison service the
probation service
who were responsible of course for the
managing officemen can back out in the
community and on that issue
the sharing of the intelligence again
the jury said
that they believe that failings by
state actors here did contribute to the
deaths of
saskia jones and jack barrett and on a
third issue another important issue
about the way in which
the event that uzman khan launched his
terrorist attack at
the the way in which that event was
managed again the jury found that
failings
in the way that event was managed
contributed to the deaths of these
two young workers in prison
rehabilitation
it had been an event by the learning
together
uh um organization which
looks after prisoner rehabilitation and
education that have been celebrating
its fifth anniversary and it carried out
uh
assembled an event at fishmongers hall
on the north side
of london bridge on the 29th of november
in 2019 saskia jones had volunteered
with learning together before
and she'd been asked if she wanted to
attend the event she attended the event
jack merritt was one of the organizers
of this learning together event and
uzman khan
who had participated in learning
together activities
was also invited along with a number of
other
ex-offenders and it's clear from the
evidence that we heard
during this inquest and from the way in
which
the jury marked out that questionnaire
at the end about
the feelings that they perceived from
the evidence that
the way in which uzman khan was managed
back in the community
the intelligence that was shared and the
way in which of course he was allowed to
travel
to london and attend eve an event that
really had
little or nothing in the way of security
checks
these were all failings which the jury
found contributed
to the deaths of saskia jones and jack
merritt